voici un an il ya jour pour jour que
j'ai pris mes fonctions de premier
président de la cour des comptes donc de
président du haut conseil des finances
publiques et en juin dernier 2020
je rejoins ainsi avec une institution
que j'avais porté sur les fonts
baptismaux en 2012 lorsque j'étais mise
des finances moi même à un moment où la
révision de la gouvernance économique et
financière était devenue nécessaire dans
le sillage double crise économique de
2008 et des dettes publiques souveraine
de 2010 2011
la crise économique et les sanitaires
que nous traversons depuis plus d'un an
nature très différente appel à un nouvel
ajustement des finances publiques de ce
cadre des finances publiques qui
reviendra tout à l'heure au cours de
l'année dernière le conseil a rendu cet
avis une activité inhabituellement
soutenue qui reflète le caractère
absolument inédite la crise et donc des
réponses qui ont été apportées de ces
différents avis il découle deux
principaux constats que je vous ai
présenté au fil des mois le premier je
le redis c'est celui de l'obsolescence
des lois de programmation des finances
publiques adoptées en
janvier 2018 qui résulte à la fois du
choc économique et de la hausse des
dépenses publiques et le second c'est
celui du caractère absolument
fondamental de la soutenabilité de nos
finances publiques a commencé par
l'endettement public après le bond de
près de 20 points de fib que nous
connaîtrons entre l'avant et l'après
crise
il conviendra de maîtriser le niveau de
la dette publique pour le faire refluer
à moyen terme
c'est une conclusion je crois robuste
sur lequel nous aurons l'occasion de
revenir
l'avis du haut conseil sur le premier
projet de loi de finances rectificative
2021 renforce la portée de ces deux
constats qui d'ailleurs se font écho et
qui appellent ensemble à la définition
le moment venu d'une nouvelle stratégie
de d'action et de finances publiques qui
prendra la forme le moment venu d'une
nouvelle voie de programmation sans
doute on peut l'imaginer à à l'aube d'un
nouveau quinquennat nouveau mandat
législatif
à cet égard j'aurai le plaisir de
revenir prochainement devant vous en
tant que premier président cette fois
pour vous exposer un ensemble de
recommandations que la cour formule pour
guider l'élaboration de cette stratégie
que nous développerons à la fois dans le
rapport sur la situation et les
perspectives des finances publiques et
dans un audit extrêmement large que
le premier ministre nous a demandé et
que j'aurai l'occasion de me remettre
dans les jours ou semaines qui viennent
s'agissant du présent avis je vous
indiquerai dans un premier temps
l'analyse que l'on conseille porte sur
les prévisions économiques du
gouvernement avant de formuler plusieurs
observations sur la trajectoire de
finances publiques
d'abord et le scénario macroéconomique
présenté par le gouvernement dans ce
collectif budgétaire confirment leur
rebond de l'activité économique après un
recul d'activité de 7,9 pour cent en
le gouvernement prévoit en effet une
croissance de 5% du pis pour 2021
prévisions inchangées par rapport à
celles présentées en avril 2021 en forme
de stabilité
il ya deux mois il est au conseil avait
qualifié ce scénario macro qu'une de
cohérent avec le scénario sanitaire
recul levée progressive à partir de mai
2021 des restrictions pesant sur les
activités les déplacements au scénario
qui sait en gros réaliser nous
maintenant aujourd'hui cette
appréciation décennale croissance du
gouvernement que nous considérons
cohérent avec les informations
conjoncturelles parus depuis avril après
une légère contraction du pib au premier
trimestre 2009
mais entre -0 ans et plus des rois
stabilité avec tendance baissière la
levée progressive des restrictions aux
déplacements et activités en mai juin
devrait permettre un rebond très nette
de l'activité
les enquêtes de conjoncture après des
entreprises publiés fin mai par l'insee
poids même présager une résorption des
pertes d'activités un peu plus rapide
conduisant à une croissance un peu plus
élevée pour la de 8,21
ce qui fait que le qualificatif
collusion de réaliste est encore
entachée d'un tout petit peu de prudence
nous avons eu un débat au sein du haut
conseil de se voir si je devais apporter
un changement de prudence ou de réalisme
le réalisme il a remporté notamment
regard des données du premier trimestre
qui ont un tout petit peu décevante mais
la prudence reste quand même
l'orientation dominante or que nous
avons retenu le qualificatif de réaliste
bien sûr la situation économique demeure
entourée d'incertitudes importantes
la première d'entre elles étant
l'évolution de la situation sanitaire
mais aussi le comportement de
consommation des ménages encore la
solvabilité des entreprises en sortie de
crise qui demeure d'importants aléas je
le redis au total parce que c'est le mot
essentiel nous considérons que la
prévision de croissance globalement de 5
% et réaliste en 2021
au regard des dernières informations
nous estimons par ailleurs les
prévisions d'emploi une masse salariale
sont plutôt prudentes l'inflation
également pour se révéler un peu
supérieur à la prévision du plfr ce qui
pourrait notamment soutenir leurs gains
des recettes publiques
j'en viens justement maintenant aux
prévisions de recettes et de dépenses du
moment depuis le et stable le cercle
finance publique a été révisée pour
prendre notamment conclu prolongement de
certains dispositifs de soutien le
niveau des dépenses publiques est ainsi
revu en très forte hausse depuis là et
les filles pour s'établir selon le plfr
à 66 points de pib en 2021 paravent à
2020 les dépenses croissent de 66
milliards d'euros soit une augmentation
de 3 6% porté avant tout par les
dépenses que je qualifierais ordinaire
dire les dépenses qui ne comprennent pas
les mesures de soutien de relance ses
dépenses ordinaires ont montré de 41
milliards d'euros cette année
les dépenses de soutien et de relance
sont également en hausse de 25 milliards
d'euros par rapport à 2020 en
particulier les crédits ouverts sur la
mission plan d'urgence à laquelle sa
libération très nettement accrue il
passe de 6 milliards d'euros loi de
finances initiale un total de 44 et plus
de 7 milliards d'euros à l'issue de ce
plfr je veux néanmoins souligné que la
majeure partie de ces crédits ont été
ouverts avant ce collectif budgétaire
par la voie réglementaire de report de
crédit fin 2020 et 2021 et ne vienne lui
milliards d'euros ouvert par le présent
plfr salute ainsi au 28 8 milliards
d'euros de crédits reportés en dépit
d'un environnement macroéconomique
meilleure qu'en 2020 le déficit public
se dégraderait donc en 2021
sous l'effet notamment de ces mesures
supplémentaires et monsieur le président
le déficit en conséquence s'établir à
9,4 points de pib en 2021 en hausse de
0,2 point par rapport à 2020 cette
prévision est entouré de deux type
d'aléas qui joue en sens inverse dans un
sens le déficit pourrait être amoindrie
pas au bond et comique plus vigoureux ou
bien par une montée en charge du plan de
relance dans un autre sens le déficit
pourrait être causée par une nouvelle
dégradation de la situation sanitaire ou
bien par l'adoption de mesures
additionnelles de soutien le report de
dépenses la réforme je pense pascal
applicables au gazole non routier
annoncé bol comme en témoigne de cette
possibilité
le scénario de finances publiques
prévoit une dégradation du solde
structurel de cinq points entre 2020 et
2021 pour s'établir à -6 3 points de pib
en 2021
c'est un mouvement très spectaculaire
jeu
devait toutefois dire qu'il convient de
ne pas accorder trop de crédit à ces
chiffres
d'abord parce qu'ils sont calculées sur
le fondement de l'hypothèse de
croissance potentielle de programmation
de janvier 2018 qui constituent comme je
le disais en introduction
nos références très clairement dépassé
lüthi l'actualisation d'hypothèses de
croissance potentiel telles qu'elles
figurent dans le paix stable conduirait
ainsi à dégrader le solde structurel
d'un point de pib supplémentaire 2021
ensuite parce que la méthode de
comptabilisation des mesures de soutien
entre 2020 et 2021 a évolué celle ci
étant considérée pour l'année dernière
comme temporaire mais c'est à dire des
rois 9 tandis qu'elles apparaissent
désormais dans le solde structurel ce
qui plaît c'est logique puisqu'un one
off sans avoir besoin d'être spécial de
l'anglais c'est quelque chose qui arrive
une fois et quand ça se paye deux fois
ça devient un peu structurelles trois
fois le pied pas de mots pour définir
c'est toujours structurelles donc voilà
à la tendance cet les gens de
comptabilisation me paralysie pour
autant l'ampleur du déficit structurel
quoi qu'il arrive elle témoigne de la
situation très dégradée des finances
publiques de la france en 2021
je ne sais pas faire preuve du
catastrophisme que de le dire c'est pas
à porter un jugement
ça se vaut qu'on sait ne le fait pas la
cour des comptes
s'exprimant à + plus en détail sur le
fond c'est simplement constater que et
bien sûr la crise sanitaire a entraîné
des mesures qui étaient nécessaires et
légitimes pour faire face à celle ci on
peut aussi la crise économique et
sociale
c'est le fameux quoi qu'il en coûte qui
compte aggraver la situation de finances
publiques elle même étendue située au
moins favorables que celles de nos
partenaires avant 2019 même s'il s'était
redressée au point que la france est
sortie de la procédure de déficit
excessif
donc tout de même une situation dégradée
avec un déficit public plus creusé en
2021 qu'en 2020 en dépit du rebond de
l'activité économique le ratio de dette
publique augmentera de 20 points de pim
entre 2019 et 2021 pour atteindre plus
de 117 points de pim ce sont 17
2 le conseil souligne à nouveau que
cette évolution appelle la plus grande
vigilance aux chemins de résorption du
déficit public et sur la soutenabilité
la trajectoire de finances publiques
dans un contexte où vous l'aurez
remarqué l'inflation sans me lasser en
europe est très présente
outre atlantique et où le niveau des
taux d'intérêt sans atteindre des
niveaux préoccupé reste préoccupant est
extrêmement bas mais nous sommes sortis
du territoire négatif de manière claire
j'aurai l'occasion devant vous de
revenir à l'occasion des présents le
prochain rapport de la cour pour affront
dire approfondir cette réflexion et pour
couvrir des pistes voilà mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs les principales
observations du conseil dans cet avis
avant de répondre à vos questions
elle souhaitait conclure en disant
quelques mots d'un sujet qui me tient à
coeur vous le savez c'est la gouvernance
des finances publiques et vous êtes en
discussion du crous homologue
l'assemblée nationale sur
une proposition de loi organique
relative à la modernisation de la
gestion des finances publiques qui
prévoit notamment d'adapter le mandat
lié au conseil sur ce point je veux dire
que je souscris aux modifications qui
sont portées par la ppl au moment
d'aller au conseil on a des raisons d'en
parler quand je suis venu présenter
notre rapport sur la gouvernance
le haut conseil est encore en réalité au
service débat démocratique
donc il est au service du parlement les
questions que vous posez au président du
conseil
bien souvent je ne peux pas y répondre
parce que ne sont pas dans notre mandat
et quand je fais le constat le
comparatif avec d'autres pays européens
mais en réalité avec lassitude des
européens je constate que le mandat de
notre conseil des finances publiques
pourrait dire j'en suis un peu coupable
puisque j'étais misé finances qui l'a
fortement mais la conjoncture
en tout cas le contexte était assez
différent 2012 il faut tirer les leçons
de ce qui s'est passé depuis
ce mandat est plus étroit
significativement que celui des autres
institutions budgétaires indépendantes
et c'est au détriment du débat public
c'est aussi au détriment je le crois de
l'information du parlement et de sa
capacité à peser dans ces débats en
particulier l'élargissement de la
compétence du haut-conseil
l'appréciation du réalisme des
prévisions de recettes et dépenses me
fiais l'examen la soutenabilité des
dettes publiques me semble absolument
nécessaires à la rénovation notre
cadence gouvernance des finances
publiques
et j'ajouterais trois ajustements
complémentaires le premier qui concerne
l'appréciation de la trajectoire
finances publiques pour que le conseil
comme le prévoit le pp l'eau puisse
apprécier le réaliste et prévient de
recettes dépenses il m'apparaît très
nécessaire qu'ils puissent également
examiné les mesures nouvelles et plus
significatives porté par les textes
financiers par exemple on pourra
envisager un seuil financier fixé par
yannick pour que cette contre expertise
soit réservé aux seules mesures qui ont
une forte incidence sa trajectoire
finances publiques le deuxième
justement concerne le suivi en continu
en quelque sorte de l'exécution d'un
trajet toi finances publiques
j'y reviendrai déjà parlé celui ci
pourrait être rendue plus opérationnels
par une procédure en quelque sorte
d'identification des risques des cas le
conseil pourrait effectivement suivre au
cours de l'année la réalisation la
trajectoire formule un avion cas de
risque des cars dont il s'agirait en
quelque sorte d'établir un mécanisme de
pré alerte complémentaire du mécanisme
actuel correction qui n'a pas pleinement
fait la preuve de son efficacité
enfin là je crois que c'est en tout cas
très consensuel le troisième ajustement
concerne la simplification et la
clarification du mandat du haut conseil
qui a tout de même quelques dispositions
qui pourraient ponctuellement ajusté je
pense notamment aux dispositions
relatives au délai de saisine qui ne
sont pas pleinement satisfaisante le
présenta ville illustre à nouveau que
puisque le conseil disposer pour
examiner le plfr de cinq jours quant à
lui finalement à moins de 3 à l'issue la
saisine rectificative été globalement il
se trouve que cette saisine modifier peu
de choses donc en réalité les 5 et les
trois se sont confondus mais ça aurait
pu être tout à fait différent c'est une
situation vous comprenez comme
parlementaire qui n'est évidemment pas
conformes ce que doit être le
fonctionnement de nos institutions
budgétaires indépendantes le jouant la
plénitude son rôle chacun je crois en
est conscient y compris au ministère des
finances
et je crois qu'il est donc tendre dit
remédier c'est à vous d'apprécier le sud
que vous souhaiterez donner à cette ppl
haut mais je suis moi très très attaché
à une modernisation du cadre gouvernance
organique des finances publiques
un travail harmonieux avec un parlement
avec votre commission et je crois que
ces réformes y contribueront voilà je
vous remercie de votre attention et je
me tiens à votre disposition pour
répondre à vos questions
merci monsieur le président vous a dit
que s'attend que ce qui concerne la
commission des finances du sénat
nous partageons moins un point c'est
d'avoir les délais nécessaires pour
travailler les dossiers cela est vrai du
plfr que nous examinons aujourd'hui
c'est vrai aussi de la gpl dont nous ne
savons pas aujourd'hui quand est ce
qu'elle se représente est réellement à
l'assemblée ça devait être certes
d'abord l'année dernière on en comprend
bien que les choses ont été impossible
ou difficile
ça devait être en début d'année ce sera
peut-être en juillet ce qui nous
renverrait nous mêmes il quelque chose
qui arriverait au cours d'ailleurs de
loi de finances 2010 21 2022 pardon donc
sont des questions que nous pourrons
partager sur les délais pour travailler
dans de bonnes conditions
sur ces dossiers là merci en tout cas
monsieur le président de présentation je
donne tout de suite le rapport là
l'apparent le rapporteur général
oui merci monsieur le président merci
monsieur le premier président et je
m'associer au point de vue que je viens
d exprimer à la fois à titre de
président mais parce que on suit la
démarche où la proposition la pp l'eau
non seulement je souscris au mot près à
ce que vient de dire claude raynal mais
je vais vous dire je suis pas sûr alors
que le pays est quand même assez
tourneboulé par la valse des milliards
la crise sanitaire
qu'on soit dans un état d'esprit qui
nous permettent alors qu'on est encore
en pleine période de crise d'avoir le
bon tempo pour analyser et finalement
décidée au regard du temps passé mais
surtout de celui qu'on vit en même temps
de la bonne mesure et de la bonne
organisation parce que j'entends les
éléments de cadrage vous les avez évoqué
un moment donné on a presque
l'impression que pratiquement ne pourra
plus bouger dans quoi je ne je nous
invite collectivement à prendre du temps
de réflexion lp vous l'avez d'ailleurs
dit on souvent les décisions prises dans
la précipitation ne sont pas les
décisions qui sont eux comment déjà à
six sur la plus grande réflexion
donc vous l'avez compris nous sommes
ouverts depuis toujours d'ailleurs à la
commission des finances
mais il faut le faire sans précipitation
avec méthode et surtout en regardant ce
qui aurait pu se passer
je veux peut-être tout de suite je vais
faire rapidement trois questions une
première vous avez évoqué concernant la
croissance un scénario vous avez
qualifié plus tôt de réaliste et en même
temps qualifié dans votre rapport en
situations de prudent je dirais
effectivement qu'il à la fois prudents
mais qu'il est aussi crédible
simplement quand on regarde la prévision
à 5% et qu'on vous voit l'eau c'est dieu
qui à 5,8
vous conviendrez que ces prêts de das un
écart qui est significatif c'est quand
même en valeur absolue près de 20% des
cas ça peut avoir des conséquences quand
on a eu des niveaux de croissance qui
sont beaucoup plus faibles
quels éléments selon vous c'est vous
pourriez avoir identifié pour expliquer
cette prévision sensiblement plus forte
faite par l' ocde
une deuxième question qui avait été
abordé dans les doutes
sur globalement l'état des finances et
de l'économie c'est le fait que depuis
janvier 2021 les les obligations à 10
ans le taux remontent assez sensiblement
pas défaut d'avoir d'ores et déjà selon
vous d'une explication
quelles conséquences ça pourrait avoir
sur l'endettement à moyen terme de notre
pays et puis peut-être enfin je partage
évidemment mais ça ne fera pas une
surprise l'attention que vous portez à
la réduction du déficit public
et vous l'avez évoqué à la trajectoire
des finances publiques qui doit être
soutenable sanou s'impose con non
seulement qu'on réfléchisse mais qu'on
fasse en sorte d'anticiper sur à la fois
la méthode est la stratégie de cette
maîtrise de la dépense publique
une fois le gros de la crise derrière
nous ce que nous souhaitons être le cas
aujourd'hui
ceci étant jusqu'à présent le
gouvernement reste complètement muet je
sais qu'on n'est pas tout à fait dans la
même séquence mais il faut anticiper
selon moi et je le disais avec avec
finalement cette valse des milliards qui
continuent d'être aigres et nés de
parent servante de
déclaration
ministériel aujourd'hui sur des dépenses
d'avenir pérenne est ce que vous ne
craignez pas qu'on ait du mal à
retrouver au moins le niveau d'avant
crise oui termes de déficit public
c'est le président voulait bien répondre
peut-être dans un premier temps
rapporteur général je me permettrai
peut-être moi même de poser une seule
petite question sur sur l'inflation et
donc sur la prévision d'inflation qui
est présenté alors vous donner quelques
maux mais est ce que vous pourriez
revenir sur les facteurs qui selon vous
pousse aujourd'hui à une remontée de
l'inflation et 12 indiqué c'est toujours
compliqué et un cycle d'inflation mais
selon vous est ce qu'elles présentent
souvent un caractère un caractère
durable qu'est ce qui pourrait amener
avoir un caractère durable à une
inflation plus élevée
et puis peut-être nous dire comment vous
voyez le duc ou la modification si tel
était le cas entre finalement ce que
vous avez évoqué c'est à dire en effet
sur la haute des recettes publiques d'un
côté mais également en parallèle et marc
le frêle heureusement un effets
éventuels sur les taux d'intérêt sur la
charge de la dette
comment vous diriez les choses
aujourd'hui parce que c'est quand même
un sujet sur lequel on on lit des choses
très disparates condamné a notamment sur
l'impact la politique américaine et
c'est ce que vous pourriez nous dire
quelques mots sur le conseil estime que
la plus haute croissance du gouvernement
pour 2021 à 5% et réaliste et vous
faites la comparaison avec cette double
cd ricky plutôt à 5,8
pourquoi expliquer comment expliquer ce
delta
d'abord le contexte d'incertitude qui
s'installe depuis début de la pandémie
invite à prendre quoi peu de recul par
rapport aux chiffres macroéconomiques à
ne pas attribuer
fait bien moins d'importance c'est
spectaculaire enfin il faut aussi
regarder quand même les chiffres absolus
une signification excessive aux chiffres
après la virgule des prévisions de
différentes institutions
nous n'en sommes plus là du gouvernement
tu me plus basses pressions
internationales
ensuite parce que ça lui consensus
forecast était considérée réaliste par
les monts du conte le conseil
essentiellement parce que quelqu'un
compte la révision à la baisse la
croissance du pib pour le premier
trimestre qui est intervenu vendredi 28
mai dernier en plein examen par le
conseil des prévisions et la révision
des comptes nationaux réduit la
croissance du pib de 0 5 point de plus
0,4 à -0 1 l'acquis de croissance pour
2021 à l'issue du premier trimestre de 0
6 point et qu'elle vient de là à 3,25 et
s'était fait explique en partie l'écart
entre le premier du gouvernement qui
tient compte de la révision et celle des
autres institutions qui ne l'intègre pas
encore donc en bonne logique ce sont les
ovations qui devrait revoir leurs
estimations légèrement à la baisse mais
pour les raisons que j'ai dit c'est à
dire la très grande incertitude dans
laquelle nous vivons la volatilité
l'élasticité la réactivité l'économie on
peut aussi attendre de bonnes surprises
c'est pourquoi encore une fois le ch
innocente % nous considérons comme
réaliste mais nous pensons qu'une paix
taux correct et il est encore un tout
petit peu prudent et qu'iliad de de la
marge est donc ça pourrait se trouver en
contre les deux encore une fois c'est
sur les taux d'intérêt d'abord les faits
les taux d'intérêt auxquels la france
emprunte ont augmenté en 2021
c'est un fait les obligations françaises
à 10 ans sont désormais à +0 17% alors
qu'elle était à -0 38 en décembre 2020
c'est une hausse qui n'est pas propre
d'ailleurs à la france qui est commune
aux états européens aux etats-unis la
hausse des taux et leurs profs let
anticipations positives dans le cas du
reconnais ma rage encore progressive des
économies
les investisseurs anticipent à la fois
un peu plus de croissance et un peu plus
d'inflation du fait de la levée
progressive des restrictions d'activités
mouvement grâce à la montée en puissance
des compagnies vaccination grâce à la
montée en puissance des plans de relance
américains européens et puis les
tensions et perturbations qui demeurent
sur les matières premières les chaînes
de production mondiale vous m'interrogez
sur les causes possibles de l'appelation
mousseux président prix énergétiques
prix des matières premières va ouverture
les services et les commerces ou les des
tremblements temporaires dans les
chaînes de production avec des effets
qu'on connaît ses dires il pourra y
avoir
une hausse persistante du condamné qui
serait favorable sur le seul public
parce que je vois sur les recettes mais
qui pourrait aussi avoir un effet
négatif sur les taux d'intérêt donc
c'est évidemment quelque chose qui est à
surveiller de très près 1 mes
prédécesseurs et commission européenne
qui ensuite est devenu premier ministre
en france raymond barre et qu'on
considérait que le maire ait commise et
franchement pas du tout ses prétentions
j'essaie de lire un petit peu de
littérature économique sur l'inflation
et je vois vraiment personnes dansaient
trop rire ce qui apparaît quand même
de manière générale c'est que les
banques centrales sont conçues confronté
à une très grande question quels traits
de mer différent selon qu'il s'agit de
la banque du japon de la fed la banque
centrale européenne savoir que quand
même
l'inflation semble de retour aux états
unis pour des raisons qui sont assez
différente de celle qui existe chez nous
avec d'ailleurs des plans de relance qui
ont différemment dimensionné certains
on sent tombé amoureux d'autres estiment
au contraire qu'ils sont un peu trop
élevé donc qui pourrait entraîner un
risque de surchauffe
c'est notamment le point de vue aussi de
madame jelen qui dit du coup qu'il
pourrait y avoir une réaction de la fed
a vécu de nouveau ses taux d'intérêt
mais ça ne crée pas de contagion
mécanique et en europe
ce qu'on observe c'est plutôt une
reprise extrêmement limité de
l'inflation qui ne semble pas de nature
à ce stade
changez l'évidence d'un briefing à terme
et je sais que je ne m'engage pas
davantage sur ce terrain car la prudence
est tout à fait le de rigueur
j'en reviens aux taux d'intérêt c'était
osé taux restent limités les taux
d'intérêt restent bas
même s'ils ne sont plus en territoire
négatif et certains pensent même que le
rideau augmentation des taux qu'on
connaît aujourd'hui serait passager a
néanmoins c'est un enjeu crucial pour la
soutenabilité nos finances publiques
et je pense qu'il faut prendre cette
remontée extrêmement légères à ce stade
est indolore comme quand même à une
piqûre de rappel
c'est à dire que penser qu'on peut faire
n'importe quoi en matière de finances
publiques parce que les taux d'intérêt
pour l'éternité sont bas est imprudent
et et j'en viens au deuxième point je
voulais évoquer là dessus c'est à dire
que si la remontée des taux observée au
cours des dernières semaines se
poursuivait aussi la s'accélérait elle
pour avoir des conséquences notables sur
la prévision d'évolution de la charge
d'intérêt et c'est un des éléments clés
auxquelles pense le conseil quand il a
fait la plus grande vigilance la
soutenabilité la trajectoire de finances
publiques à moyen terme
comme vous l'avez noté là
un char de la dette s'est réduite avec
la baisse des taux mais la forte
croissance de la dette publique la rend
plus sensible à une hausse des taux
d'intérêt donc c'est un point de
vulnérabilité incontestable pour nos
l'agencé france trésor elle même si ma
6e hausse d'un point du taux d'intérêt
en gérer la charge d'intérêts la dette
de 2 5 milliards d'euros la première
année est de 28,9 milliards d'euros à
l'horizon de dix ans qui d'estimation
plus fortes que celles qui étaient
réalisés avant la crise sanitaire donc
point de vigilance absolument
incontestable là dessus même si c'est
pas encore un point d'alerter j'espère
que ça ne deviendra pas sur le déficit
public
je ne vais pas m'engager beaucoup sur
cette question à ce stade je reviendrai
dans le cas du rapport sur la situation
et perspectives des finances publiques
pour c'est le rôle dans le cadre de
l'audit au premier ministre également
lui dirai simplement en réponse à la
question du rapporteur général que oui
bien sûr il a raison revenir au déficit
d'avant crise je rappelle qu'à l'époque
la france étaient sorties de procès en
déficit excessif et n'avait pas été la
première j'en sais quelque chose pour
avoir traité ce sujet de l'autre côté de
la frontière belge mais au nom de
l'union européenne la belgique et
c'était pas
les sorties la plus spectaculaire
puisque on était encore autour de 3%
il n'empêche que pour revenir à ce type
de déficit au niveau d'avant crise il
faudra je dirais en toute hypothèse du
temps et même pas mal de temps donc
toute la question c'est combien de temps
et quels sont les choix qui seront faits
pour infléchir la courbe de la dette et
la courbe des déficits
j'aurai l'occasion de vous présenter là
dessus des scénarios un peu plus élaboré
ce n'était pas le rôle
l'avis du haut conseil des finances
publiques mais bon évidemment monsieur
repartent en général vous avez raison
nous ne sommes pas prêts d'y revenir
il faudra plusieurs années et ce n'est
même pas une donnée en soi donc c'est
une question de choix mais de débat
public et politique
merci monsieur le président nous allons
poursuivre et des questions de nos
collègues donc marc laménie puis roger
karoutchi
oui merci monsieur le président merci
monsieur le président du haut conseil
des finances publiques au jeu ma
question elle sera simple concernant je
dirais ce projet de loi de finances
rectificative
ça serait aussi dans le cadre du plan de
relance qui peut votre position ou
analyse concernant le lien entre l'état
les collectivités territoriales sur les
collectivités territoriales
bon l'état est son premier partenaire
financier des collectivités
territoriales et ce sont des acteurs
importants en termes de relance pour
soutenir le secteur du bâtiment et des
travaux publics
donc en termes de finances publiques
qu'elle est un petit peu l'impact qui
touche aussi les qui a fait que
directement ou indirectement les
collectivités territoriales j'en
remercie mais aussi marc roger karoutchi
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier président moi je fais une
observation puis une question une
observation
chacun va reconnaître mon optimisme
légendaire
j'ai l'impression que l'eau printemps
dernier je disais à bruno le maire mais
vos provisions sont sympathiques mais
nous ne sommes pas sortis la crise
sanitaire
la réponse de bruno le maire avait été
de me dire mais on n'est pas sûr du tout
qui est une deuxième vague
depuis comment dire on a eu quelques
soucis et le rapporteur de la mission
d'information coheed que je suis pour le
scénar est d'autant plus inquiet que les
dernières auditions faits ne sont pas
très rassurantes ambre certes nous
vaccinons mais on voit bien que
l'australie reconfirment que l'amérique
latine ou l'asie du sud est ne sont pas
un détail que dans le sud-ouest de la
france
l'épidémie repas est-ce que ça c'est
l'observation est ce que la volonté du
gouvernement de faire comme si la crise
sanitaire a été derrière nous et d'avoir
des espèces de prospective comme s'ils
vont aller maintenant sur le au travail
on va certes on le voit encore aidés
subventionnés mais nous n'avons plus le
choc sanitaire lui-même est ce que tout
ça n'est pas quand même désespérément
optimiste
un point de telles que ce ne soit pas
réaliste et ma question
elle est un peu différente même si elle
est liée ces dernières années alors
surtout ces derniers 18 mois
mais en réalité depuis plus longtemps
que ça le quoi qu'il en coûte est devenu
comment dire une espèce d'idée d'un
gouvernement qui veut rassurer sa
population qui veut le calme social mais
qui en réalité nous met dans des
situations épouvantables
autant prendre en charge les besoins
sociaux est une nécessité absolue
autant dire publiquement que quelques
quoi qu'il en coûte
on va dépenser et on va prendre en
charge c'est financièrement une folie on
voit bien que les états voisins ne l'ont
pas fait ne l'ont pas fait et ils ont
pas eu plus de morts ou plus de deux ans
hospitalisé que nous et deuxième élément
est ce que monsieur le premier président
quand vous dites oui pour réduire le
déficit il faudra plusieurs années
comment est ce que une population va
réagir quand après avoir eu tous les
droits
toutes les possibilités l'argent facile
l'argent distribué vous allez lui dire
oh là là ça n'est plus possible il faut
réduire les déficits
il va falloir faire des efforts est-ce
que c'est compréhensible dans l'opinion
publique
si on a instauré installer l'idée de
quoi qu'il en coûte
l'état est là et je dis et je conclus là
dessus le président du soft était venu
nous dire qu'on arrête le quoi qu'il en
coûte
il s'est fait taper sur les doigts et le
résultat des courses c'est que depuis
cinq mois on est revenu à bon on y va
mais même le ministre du budget était
bien conscient ya six mois que c'était
impossible à tenir il l'a dit roger
chaotique il est connu dans cette
commission pour amener une image comment
dire optimiste de la situation
il dit et il ira
il dira lui-même plus crédible alors
michel canevet depuis nous aurons
quelques collègues en ligne merci
monsieur le président que je partage
totalement les inquiétudes de roger
karoutchi là dessus parce que et quels
seront les appréhensions de la
population et des corps intermédiaires
après savoir effectivement eu des
réponses fortes à des demandes légitimes
quand il va falloir que la rigueur
s'instaure alors monsieur le premier
président effectivement on analyse un
peu les perspectives budgétaires selon
un certain nombre de données d'évolution
du pib et cetera
moi j'ai quelques questions d'abord est
ce que le haut conseil a pu évaluer un
peu l'impact des dans sa tombe de
politique menée sur la croissance future
est ce que je veux dire par là est-ce
que l'essentiel des dépenses selon le
haut conseil sont vraiment destiné à
permettre une véritable croissance dans
notre pays
seconde question on peut s'interroger
sur nous en tant que législateur sur la
réalité des données qui ne sont
communiqués puisque opl fr 4 il n'y a
pas si longtemps nous annoncer un
déficit du budget de l'état de 223
milliards d'euros
et puis la loi le projet de loi de
règlement nous donne un projet de
déficit à 178 milliards d'euros
c'est-à-dire un écart quand même tout à
fait significatif qui nous fait nous
poser la question de la sincérité des
propositions qui nous sont formulées
dans ses projets budgétaires quand
pensez-vous qu'en france le haut conseil
des finances publiques pardon et puis
troisième et dernière question c'est
qu'on voit là le budget de l'état mais
il ya aussi une composante forte de d&d
déficit public qui est celui des
administrations de la sécurité sociale
dont le déficit était prévue un peu
moins de 50 milliards
avez vous assez stade de l'année des
informations sur les perspectives que
pourrait avoir ce l'obligé de déficit du
budget de la sécurité sociale pour 2021
on voit bien monsieur le président est
monsieur le premier président que les
questions de nos collègues est
évidemment toujours en quête aussi bien
sûr travail publié président que sur
celui de président du haut conseil
mais vous ferez sans doute une réponse
aujourd'hui une réponse plus complète
dans quelques dans quelques jours
maintenant
ce que j'espère en tout cas espérons
bien merci
nous avons en ligne philippe dallier
puis christian bilhac c'est bonjour
monsieur le président mon anglais vous
au travail
très bien merci écoutez dans le genre
pessimistes sont là on va continuer mine
à continuer à te dois vous faire part de
mon sentiment de d'être un peu comme en
apesanteur depuis hier depuis un certain
nombre de mois avec comment
effectivement le sentiment partagé par
beaucoup de français
bon ben la crise est là mais au nom de
quoi qu'il en coûte on peut répondre à
toutes les demandes et à toutes les
attentes
et on voit bien que la campagne
présidentielle se dessinant à l'automne
prochain
on se demande d'ailleurs si les
candidats futurs ou le courage de dire à
certains de mes chaussures mois
difficiles mais tout ceci étant dit
est-ce que l'info du jour ça n'est pas
tout simplement la tribune de regrets
chaud le danchaud bleus dans le
finançons le times qui semble marquer de
l'autre côté de lure à une certaine
impatience et et notamment vis-à-vis de
la france parce que je pense que c'est
ainsi qu'il faut le lire et donc comme
je ne vois pas se dessiner le moment où
nous allons expliquer aux français
comment nous allons entrer c'est la
situation et a mon avis à un rythme qui
va probablement devoir être plus
important que ce qu'on avait pu imaginer
notamment si les taux d'intérêt
remontent et je voulais savoir si le
premier président pouvait nous donner un
avis sur cette tribune de monsieur
choqué merci merci et philippe christian
bilhac
christian
nous n'entendons rien il faut voilà le
micro est ouvert merci christian merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
président je voulais poser la question
sur la situation des collectivités
territoriales mais notre rôle est de
marque la médina reposer alors moi je
crois qu'il faut d'abord avoir reçu l'on
peut rappeler de la prudence la modestie
de l'afrique à l'heure actuelle puisque
à l'automne dernier on nous présentait
diverses prévisions et qui étaient
parlées sur une disparition de la
pandémie et on sait ce qu'il est advenu
de roubles au bac
il serait sage de ne pas aller c'est que
d'ores et déjà là la pandémie est
derrière nous et qu'on va retrouver une
situation sanitaire normal ça se peut
mais ce n'est pas certain
alors je crois que la simplification
région pal chaque sortie d'affaires avec
la machination
mais il ya de quoi être très crus l'âge
leur est faite
eh bien je crois qu'il ya eu une mesure
d'urgence c'est vrai que le coiffe il
ajouté il faudra le payer
il faut avoir le courage de le dire à
nos concitoyens mais je crois que c'est
quand même il y avait des mesures de
deux soutiennent des mesures d'urgence
je lui fallait prendre mais après ces
mesures de relance après le train tu
manges je te dirai il faudra passer à la
cova les sages et à la rééducation et la
question c'est dans le celte situation
difficile sur le plan financier sur les
équilibres financiers et bien falloir
faire des choix et ma question c'est
quelles sont les actions qui seront
repris et d'en être prioritaire sur le
plan budgétaire dans les prochaines
échéances
merci merci christian je pense que nous
continuerons dans ce débat plutôt vers
le premier président donc je vais
m'adresser au président et ne veut bien
nous apporter quelqu'un quelques
éléments d'appréciation le président de
la commission des finances est
naturellement un sage qui équivaut bien
les problèmes et c'est tout
pourquoi je me permets de redire qu'il
est nécessaire d'élargir le mandat du
haut conseil des finances publiques
parce que on ne peut pas jouer avec les
casquettes les questions que vous posez
sont des questions qui en réalité ne
sont pas toutes du mandat du haut
conseil est théoriquement dans un
univers bien conçu une institution
budgétaire indépendante devrait pouvoir
vous délivrer des avis économique un peu
plus éclairés et donc je vais jongler
entre les deux casquettes mais très
honnêtement le fait même de ces
questions plaide pour avoir un
élargissement raisonnable du mandat du
conseil des finances publiques pour que
nous ayons tout simplement un débat plus
éclairés et pour pouvoir ensuite le
tourner vers celui auquel les uns les
autres comme institution nous avons à
rendre des comptes c'est à dire le site
est bon je ferme cette parenthèse et je
vais essayer de vous répondre
on mélange ans après les choses tout
choix sur les collectivités locales
comme sur la dette sociale est
évidemment là pour le coup ce sont plus
des questions qui s'adresse à la cour
des comptes et j'aurai l'occasion d'y
revenir dans la présentation de
plusieurs rapports nous vous le rapport
sur la situation et perfidie finances
publiques le rapport d'audit au premier
ismo s'ils rapportent 2
formation qui traitent des finances
publiques locales disons toutefois et
bien sûr à la rentrée le rapport sur les
lois de financement de la sécurité
sociale puisque la cour est compétente
pour apprécier trois ordres de compte
dans le contexte de crise lé collectif
budgétaire de printemps et de juin 2020
ont décidé que des mesures de soutien
aux collectivités locales
il s'agissait de lisser l'impact de la
crise sur les recettes ça me connecter
le plan de relance n'apporte pas de
modification substantielle à ces mesures
en revanche ce qui est nouveau c'est la
territorialisation du plan de relance
qui passe par un pilotage régional et
local de france relance qui associe
l'état territorial et quand il cale du
contrat de plan état région notamment
été adapté ce contexte de relance mais
encore une fois j'aurai l'occasion de
vous présenter un panorama plus solides
à la fois sur les finances sociales et
sur les finances locales à d'autres
moments j'ai apprécié en effet le petit
misme non pas du sénat mais c'était
certains de ses membres tués
alors pour le coup une prudence parce
que il conseille le souligne monsieur le
sénateur karoutchi le déficit ce site
pour être creusée par une éventuelle
dégradation de la situation sanitaire
nous ne pouvons pas faire comme si la
crise où la pandémie était derrière nous
elle ne l'est pas il était en même temps
une du rôle de l'exécutif d'une part de
prendre les mesures sanitaires
nécessaires et d'autre part de soutenir
la relance des activités économiques
dans un contexte où qu'ils ont le
scénario central est tout de même que
nous allons vers de meilleurs jours même
si comme vous le soulignez il faut être
extrêmement vigilants sur les
indicateurs nationaux d'un nationaux
locaux sur la progression des variants
mais on voit bien où sont les aléas et
dans cette affaire depuis maintenant un
an et demi on voit bien que la situation
sanitaire la situation économique la
situation de finances publiques sont en
réalité étroitement corrélées et que le
déterminant de base c'est bien sûr la
situation sanitaire et cela le restera
tant que nous ne sommes pas pour le coup
totalement derrière cette crise sur est
sûre sur le cloud quoi qu'il en coûte
le jugement que nous pouvons porter et
nuancée parce que incontestablement
chacun put constater et appelait
d'ailleurs au rôle de l'état et
l'importance du rôle l'état pour
stabiliser la macroéconomie pour
préserver la croissance et je pense
qu'il se trouvera personne pour dire
qu'ils ne fallait pas prendre les
mesures
importantes qui ont été prises pour en
permettre le soutien à ceux qui étaient
privés d'activités pour soutenir les
entreprises pour préserver la cohésion
sociale et je me distingue un petit peu
de vous monsieur le sénateur mais
j'aurai l'occasion d'y revenir dans les
rapports que je présenterai plus tard
notre sentiment c'est qu'en gros les
différents pays européens ont fait à peu
près la même chose et que c'est un
mouvement coordonné au niveau de l'union
européenne avec le soutien la banque
centrale européenne qui était la réponse
à la crise ça signifie pas que notre
situation soit elle meilleure en termes
de finances publiques que celle de nos
voisins ce n'est pas le cas elle est à
bien des égards plus dégradée mais en
termes de réponse disons que c'est assez
comparable
mais bien sûr on a besoin d'un débat
maintenant sur la soutenabilité de la
dette en sortie de crise et sur la
sortie du bois qui n'écoute pas ce que
je veux pas du tout intervenir dans ce
débat politique ce n'est plus mon métier
je suis tenu devoir d'impartialité et
d'indépendance auquel je me tiendrai
donc je serai dans la fonction que
damiel quelques longues années et que
j'espère de l année il est tout à fait
fondamental que nous soyons à même de
sortir du quoi qu'il en coûte
et c'est ce qui se fait tout de même des
mesures d'urgence ont petit à petit
débranchez alors à vous d'apprécier si
c'est trop vite passé vite pour
certaines pour d'autres mais les mesures
d'urgence ne vont pas durer pour
l'éternité
on passera à une situation d'après et
c'est là où je vous rejoins pour le dire
différemment
nous avons un besoin de pédagogie
absolument fondamental on ne peut pas
laisser croire
nick les mesures pour se plonger pour
l'éternité ce n'est déjà pas le cas ni
que la dépense publique peut croître
infiniment ça n'est pas possible ni que
dette publique en soi n'est pas un
problème unis que les taux d'intérêt
sont pour l'éternité une garantie parce
qu'on a observé un moment absolument
magique on entende était et la charge pc
mais toujours les taux d'intérêt
remontent
c'est l'inversé qui se produit pour le
coup l'importance du stock de dette
devient tout à fait déterminante c'est
pourquoi de manière tu es tu sors et je
cour des comptes et le haut conseil des
finances publiques devant vous et en
particulier
d'être développeront cette idée qu'il
faut absolument assurer la soutenabilité
de la dette à moyen terme après il ya
des chemins politique pour le faire
c'est pas notre rôle
mais c'est absolument je crois vital et
indispensable
j'ai été interrogé sur la classification
des dépenses entre l'urgence et la
relance et s'est mué extrêmement
compliquée avant le sait lui-même de
plus en plus floue au fil des mois avec
deux raisons d'abord que et les
dispositions à la frontière du soutien
et de la relance
je prends le cadre de l'activité
partielle et ensuite parce que la
comptabilisation de démesure diffèrent
selon la comptabilité qu'on retient
exige de comptabilité nationale
le contest budgétaire même si nous
efforçons dans notre avis de réconcilier
ces deux pôles sur sur graal je reviens
quand même message central
il faut absolument faire de la pédagogie
ou commencé à faire de la pédagogie sur
ce qui se déroulera dans l'après crise
et sur l'état de nos finances publiques
et de soutenabilité
c'est le rôle de la cour des comptes à
vos côtés
et ça nous l'assumerons non pas avec
alarmisme mais simplement en prenant en
compte les différents pas l'art
paramètres et c'est à brillac
m'interrogeais sur la piste vous savez
au fond elles sont toujours de trop
nature il y aura une action
indispensable sur la croissance toute
stratégie de finances publiques à moyen
terme repose sur une stratégie de
croissance et nous voyons bien qu'il
faut rétablir la croissance potentielle
dans notre pays et la croissance
effective
nous voyons bien qu'il ya des
investissements à faire nous voyons bien
qu'il faut mettre l'accent sur la
qualité de la dépense publique pour
privilégier l'investissement on pense
notamment à la transition écologique ont
tendance à la transition numérique
également mais je vous le dis aussi
comme je le pense
la croissance ne suffira pas seul puisse
imaginer qu'on peut se soustraire à
toute réflexion sur la dépense publique
ne serait pas non plus n'a quelque chose
de réaliste ou d'honnête
alors là je n'ai revu de dépenses seront
indispensables enfin il ya un débat qui
est un débat très politique sur lequel
je ne m'engagerai pas quel débat sur les
prélèvements obligatoires et que j'ai
été dans une autre vie un ministre qui
avait parlé de ras-le-bol fiscale ça m'a
coûté peut-être cher politiquement dans
cette villa mais j'assume quand même je
pense qu'il ya un moment où le
consentement à l'impôt est touché par
niveau des impôts ça veut pas dire qu'on
va toucher structure d'impôt aux
rapports entre les impôts ou compenser
des prélèvements nouveaux par d'autres
suppressions je ne sais pas même ça
c'est un sujet enfin bref on voit bien
quels sont les trois leviers seul je
n'aurais pas dû parler en fait des
recettes s'est tout de suite un sujet
qui fait frémir mais en tout cas la
croissance les dépenses ça ça me paraît
d'une clarté absolue mon aventure est
évident sur l'article de wolfgang
schauble
bon c'est donc à chabeuil quelqu'un je
connais bien puisque il a été mon
homologue communiste et finances nous
n'avions pas forcément là les toujours
les opinions ne participe pas au même
famille politique mais c'est un ami pour
quelqu'un pour qui j'ai une une estime
et d'admiration absolument sans borne
pour son courage pour son intelligence
et j'ai lu son papier il ya plusieurs
points qui me paraissent de bon sens et
quand ils pointent le risque une
expansion budgétaire et monétaire qui
seraient trop mécanique et là encore je
le redis à un moment donné il faut quand
même retrouver un chemin de
responsabilité simplement parce que non
pas que le chemin de la crise était
irresponsable mais on a fait ce qu'on
devait passer la crise quand cette crise
sera passée il faudra revenir une
situation qui soit plus j'adore normal
une seat aussi un peu keynes quand ça
arrange fille parle pas de l'excédent
allemand par exemple ça c'est un débat
que nous avons eu pendant des années y
compris quand j'étais ensuite
commissaire européen parce que il ya des
déséquilibres macroéconomiques qui sont
les déficits déficit
budgétaire mais aussi déficit de balance
des paiements il y a un aux
déséquilibres macroéconomiques
asymétrique qui est l'important excédent
qui ne soit budgétaires ou de balance
courante parce que ça contribue aussi à
a créé une sur épargne
en tout cas je pense que cette tribune a
un grand mérite qui de rappeler qu'il
est nécessaire de mûrir le débat au
niveau européen sur la gouvernance
économique et budgétaire et que nous
reviendrons tôt ou tard une approche de
finances publiques qui prenne en compte
la situation de celles ci et pour la
france il faut la prendre en compte pour
elle même aussi en comparaison avec les
autres dans ce cadre européen enfin sur
la sincérité du budget de l'état le
conseil n'est pas compétent pour
exprimer un jugement sur le réalisme des
prévisions de dépenses de l'état tout
cas pas à ce stade ci revient revanche
monaco dans son rapport aux solutions de
bugey l'état a souligné l'ampleur des
reports de crédits de 2020 sur 2021
elle souligne que ces 30 milliards
d'euros de crédits reportés ne sont pas
à son sens conforme aux principes
budgétaires l'annualité car les
exercices annuels sont brouillées par
les transferts d'enveloppés là vous
voyez bien que du cool enveloppe
supplémentaire et quelques 9 milliard
d'euros
finalement assez limité mais il faut
l'ajouter au 28 de 8 reporter ça pose
comme une certaine
question voilà les questions que de
réponses que je le souhaitais vous
apporter en par avance me réjouissante
pour être plus spécifique et plus précis
dans le cadre de la présentation député
prochain rapport d'accord encore une
fois vous disiez que c'était un
quatrième fois que je vis ici je pense
que nous aurons l'occasion de revoir les
prochaines semaines puisque entre le
rapport sur la situation et les
perspectives des finances publiques
rapport au premier ministre j'espère
qu'ils sont délivrés en même temps on
n'en l'occasion d'avoir pour le coup un
débat s'est approfondie ce sont deux
rapports quand je connais déjà qu'ils
sont grandes qualités de grandes
ambitions plus de rapport sur les
finances publiques locales comment venue
sur les finances sociales
à l'occasion je pense d'approfondir tous
de tous ces débats mais je voudrais
quand même finir par marquer quelques
messages quand même extrêmement simple
qui sont qu' il faut prendre en compte
la situation de nos finances publiques
telles qu'elles sont
il fallait répondre crise ça a été fait
dans un cadre européen est comparable à
ce qui a été fait ailleurs le résultat
tout de même que nous aussi que les
finances publiques se sont dégradées
le haut conseil souligne la question de
la soutenabilité de la dette publique
est une question absolument fondamental
est là pour y faire face il faudra bien
faire des choix et des choix la fois en
termes d'action publique et de finances
publiques
nous serons là à vos côtés pour
alimenter ce débat pour l'éclairer non
pas pour eux nous substituer à qui que
ce soit mais pour jouer notre bon plan
merci monsieur le président vous l'avez
dit dix et quelques questions puis
réponse que je souhaitais donner parce
qu'il reste effectivement vous l'avez
senti quelques questions qui
nécessiteront quelques réponses vous
venez de le redire plus approfondie
est-ce que vous avez une idée justement
sur ces deux rapports et sur leur
concomitance dans le la présentation
ou à ce stade il n'y a toujours pas de
date de remise du rapport au premier
ministre russe tu as qu'on peut espérer
sa fin je fin juin un peu plus tard
comment quoi envoyer l'eau les choses
alors le rapport sur la situation et les
perspectives des finances publiques est
un rapport qu'il dut au parlement avant
la fin juin et les délais seront en
tenue et d'armement tenue pour ce qui
est du rapport au premier ministre
ça ne dépend pas de nous c'est prendre
des autorités de l'état
j'ai bon espoir que ce soit
également bien avant la fin juin il sera
d'ailleurs assez logique que ce rapport
soit délivré à son destinataire
avant l'autre j'y travaille je suis
plein plein plein d'espoir en toute
hypothèse le râleur spf et sera prêt à
temps
l'autre rapport est prêt aussi donc moi
je suis les starting blocks ou et
poussins produire ça sera compliqué
d'évoquer l'un sans l'autre voyez ce que
je me dis c'est lorsqu'il serait
pertinent d'abord d'évoquer l'un avec
l'autre et ensuite que les deux dit la
même chose à peu près
[Musique]